GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE GOING TO
CALL THE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO ORDER. WE DO
HAVE A THREE MEMBER SERVING AS
REPLACEMENT SO THANK YOU TO
THOSE MEMBERS WE HAVE MISTER
GIBSON. MISTER GLORIA AND MISS
RAY HAS SERVING AS REPLACEMENTS
ARE SO THANK YOU. FOR BEING
HERE.
NO PLOT.
STILL CAN.
WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU.
WE NEED ONE MORE SO GOING AWAY
FOR ONE MORE PERSON BEFORE WE
CALL QUORUM BUT WE ARE GOING TO.
.
CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER.
THEY WE'RE GONNA START WITH.
MISS COSTA AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO THROUGH S. B. I WOMAN SIX SP
ONE ONE PAID S. B. ONE TWENTY S.
B. ONE TWENTY.
THIS COST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
STERN VICE CHAIR MEMBERS IN COST
BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
YOU NOTED WE HAVE ONE CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET BILL JUNIOR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SEVERAL
TRAILER BILLS FOR THAT
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION. THE
FIRST BILL AT THE ONE SIX
TEAM IS THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW UP TO FIVE PERCENT.
FOR I HAD THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO ADMINISTER THE.
LOCAL UPDATE AT THE CENSUS
ADDRESS PROGRAM WHICH IS A
PROGRAM THAT WE.
ADMINISTER WITH LOCAL COUNTIES
AS PART OF THE US CENSUS COUNTS.
ON THE BILL ALSO REMOVES THE
REFERENCE TO THE CENSUS OUTREACH
COORDINATOR WHICH WILL INSTEAD
BE FUNDED THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
QUESTION IS COST OF GOING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ON S. B..
ONE ONE SIX.
OUR BUDGET.
JUNIOR BILL MODIFICATION MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ACOSTA.
THE UNDERSTAND THE NECESSITY OF
ADMINISTERING GRANT PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THIS ONE. ARE WHY DID WE
NOT REALIZE WHEN WE FIRST.
DEVELOP THE BUDGET FOR THIS
PROGRAM THAT AN EXTRA FIVE
PERCENT WAS GONNA NEED TO BE
WITHHELD FOR ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS UNIQUE IN THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T ADMINISTER THAT
MANY PROGRAMS AND SO IT WAS ARE
MISTAKEN OVERSIGHT WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY INCLUDED THE
APPROPRIATION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
WHAT'S GOING TO VOTE.
OKAY KUWAIT.
MA'AM SECRETARY BEFORE MOVE ON
COULD WE TAKE ROLL PLEASE.
TING AYE AYE HERE. OVER NOTHING.
ALAN.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CUMPLIR.
CHAVEZ.
CHIU.
CHOI.
COOPER.
FONG.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
HARPER.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LIMON MATHIS.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
WHAT FUTURE?
PATTERSON.
REYES.
RUBIO.
STONE.
VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WHAT?
CORD WAS PRESENT.
TAKING YOUR MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU.
OUR WITHOUT OING BACK TO SP ONE
ONE SIX
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN FAVOR OF
SB ONE ONE SIX.
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY SEEING NINE ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB ONE ONE SIX.
AND MARK FROM.
IT IS THEIR PUBLIC COMMENT NO I
MEAN THAT'S A COMMENT ON THE
MEMBERS WILL BE READY TO.
OKAY KNOW THEN.
.
LET LET'S LET'S.
BUT ON THE BILL.
TING. I TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ALLEN.
BUT RAMBLING. RAMBLING I BLOOM.
BLOOM I COMPARE.
CLICK HERE I CHAVEZ. CHáVEZ CHI
CHU CHOI.
COOPER I'D COOPER AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LOW MOAN MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
YEAH I MELENDEZ MULLIN PURSUIT
SHE PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE
RADIUS.
GRAY AS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
I SEE TEAM.
THANK YOU ON THIS COST SB ONE
ONE EIGHT.
THANK YOU SB ONE ONE EIGHT IS A
TRAILER BILL WHICH DEALS WITH
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT IT WOULD
ALLOW THE THREE MAIN CANNABIS
LICENSING ENTITIES TO PROCESS
FBI BACKGROUND CHECKS WHICH ARE
NEEDED TO ISSUE ANNUAL LICENSE
SAYS. THE FBI WAS REQUIRING THAT
EACH ENTITY IS SPECIFIED ON IN
STATUTES RECEIVE THE FBI
CONVICTION INFORMATION RELATED
TO CANNABIS LICENSES THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES A TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION FROM THE CANNABIS
CONTROL FUND. A WHICH IS
ACTUALLY DRIVEN FROM E. GENERAL
FUND LOAN TO SUPPLY PROPRIETARY
PLANT AND PACKAGE ON A RADIO
FREQUENCY IDENTIFICATION TAGS TO
BE USED BY ANNUAL LICENSEES TO
TRACK CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
RELATED PRODUCTS.
THE COST WAS NOT KNOWN AT THE
TIME OF ENACTMENT OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT.
BUT THIS APPROPRIATION IS
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT THE TRACK
AND TRACE SYSTEM HOW FOR ANNUAL
LICENSEES.
THE COMMITMENT.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS ROBOT.
SOME IT'S COSTA REGARDING THE
TEN POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION FOR THE RFID TAGS
THAT'S A CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
APPRPRIATION AND. OF MY
QUESTION IS I. WORLDLY ISSUING
TEMPORARY LICENSES RIGHT NOW AND
THOSE LICENSE HOLDERS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TRACK AND TRACE PROGRAM SO I WAS
WONDERING WHY WE NEEDED A
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
APPROPRIATION. INSTEAD OF DOING
THIS AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON.
I CAN'T COUNT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE
SO.
FBI BACKGROUND CHECK LANGUAGE
WILL ALLOW US TO ISSUE IN NO
LICENSES AND THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IS HOW IMPLEMENTED TRACK
AND TRACE SYSTEM WHICH WE HOPE
TO DO IN ADVANCE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT. SO
ONCE THAT LANGUAGES AVAILABLE
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE COMPLETED
WE CAN ISSUEANYA LICENSES
WITHIN TEN DAYS THEY HAVE TO
COMPLETE THE TRAINING AND THE
TRACK ENTRY SYSTEM AND HAVE
THIRTY DAYS TO EMPLOY ABOUT PUT
ALL THEIR.
INVENTORY IN THE SYSTEM SO THAT
IS OUR MECHANISM TO GET THE
LICENSEE GROUPS INTO THE TRACK
ENTRY SYSTEM IN THIS PUBLICIST
ACTUALLY DIE AND WE NEED THOSE
TAGS TO DO THAT. IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE FBI BACKGROUND CHECK
LANGUAGE
SO TO BE CLEAR WHAT IT WHAT I
HEAR YOU SAYING IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE. PERMANENT
LICENSEES THAT OUR PARTICIPATING
IN TRACK AND TRACE BEFORE. THE
BUDGET ACT GOES INTO EFFECT ON
JULY FIRST THAT'S THE INTENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE MAKING THE
CHANGE WE IT'S CONTINGENT UPON
THE FBI AGREEING TO THE
STATUTORY CHANGES AND THEN
PROVIDING THE CONVICTION
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED.
TIM CLEAR SOMEONE ON A
BACKGROUND CHECK OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE MIDST COST I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE A STATEMENT TO RESPOND ON.
SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND.
IMPLEMENTATION
THAT'S CORRECT MISTER CHAIR.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROVISION AND WE HAVE COMMITTED
HIGH TO CONTINUE THAT WORK WITH
A MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE. ON
POTTER IMPLEMENTATION RELATED
PROP SIXTY FOUR. OF WHICH
INCLUDE THAT AS PROVIDING
MONTHLY UPDATES TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS PROGRESSING.
THANK YOU AND I IMAGINE THAT
WILL BE DOING IMPLEMENTATION
FOR.
QUITE AWHILE FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM.
THE MEMBERS
OKAY SING UNLESS GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. AYE ANYBODY IN FAVOR OF
SB ONE ONE EIGHT.
KAREN LEGATUM FROM MARYSVILLE
AND I AM IN FAVOR OF THIS AS
LONG AS THEY A FRAUD IS.
WE ARE TAKING CARE OF.
BECAUSE THE POT INDUSTRY DOES TO
A LOT OF FRAUD.
SO TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO ARE
AND.
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE FEDERAL
LAW.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN FAVORITE SP ONE
ONE EIGHT.
ANYONE OPPOSED TO SP ONE WHAT
IT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
OKAY.
SEEING NONE LET'S.
MODOC.
TING AYE.
TING AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE
AYE ALLEN. ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE COMING LATER. CLEAR I
TRAVIS CHáVEZ AYE CHIU.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE COOPER.
COOPER I TONG.
FONG I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LOW MOAN MATHIS.
MATHIS FIGHT MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN
RESEARCHING PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I READ REYES.
REYES AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
WHAT I?
THANKS TWENTY.
THANK YOU
A MOVIE ON THE SP ONE TWENTY
HUMAN SERVICES THIS COST.
THANK YOU SB ONE TWENTIES ARE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
CONTAINS THREE PROVISIONS THE
FIRST PROVISION DEALS WITH THE
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM IT CLARIFIES FOR
COUNTIES THAT NEGOTIATE A WAGE
SUPPLEMENT FOR AYE EACH.
AT THAT PROVIDERS THE TIMING FOR
WHEN THE WAGE SUPPLEMENT CAN BE
APPLIED TO THE COUNTIES
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDER RATE.
I WOULD NOT THE ADMINISTRATION
COUNTIES AND LABOR SUPPORT THIS
LANGUAGE THE SECOND PROVISION
HAS TO DO WITH FOSTER CARE AND
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL DELAYS.
THE LANGUAGE PROVIDES FOR
PAYMENTS TO RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
TO BEGIN PRIOR TO THE RESOURCES
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS BEING
COMPLETED UNTIL JULY FIRST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE MAJOR
COMPONENTS ARE AS FOLLOWS.
FOSTER CARE PAYMENTS TO NON
FEDERALLY ELIGIBLE RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS ARE REQUIRED ON A
PROSPECTIVE BASIS.
TO RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL IF
THE CHILD HAS BEEN PLACED WITH
THE CARE. EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE
PAYMENTS TO NON RELATIVE
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FEDERALLY ELIGIBLE RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS ARE REQUIRED ON A
PROSPECTIVE BASIS PRIOR TO
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL IF THE
CHILD HAS BEEN PLACED WITH THE
CAREGIVER. THE STATE WILL COVER
THE COUNTIES NON FEDERAL SHARE
OF THESE PAYMENTS FOR UP TO
SIXTY DAYS.
IF A COUNTY CAN DEMONSTRATE GOOD
BECAUSE WE'RE SUBMITS A PLAN TO
ELIMINATE THEIR RFA BACKLOG. UP
BY SEPTEMBER FIRST OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE STATE WILL CONTINUE
TO COVER THE COUNTY SHARE OF
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE COSTS FOR
UP TO SIXTY DAYS. THROUGH THE
END OF JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THIS LANGUAGE PROVIDE SHORT
TERM.
SOLUTION FOR CAREGIVERS
EXPERIENCING DELAYED RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL BY ALLOWING
PAYMENTS TO FLOW PRIOR TO THEIR
APPROVAL. THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENDS TO PROPOSE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S CAN'T AYE
CONSIDERATION AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISE PROCESS.
LASTLY THE TRAILER BILL BEFORE
YOU CONTAINS PROVISIONS TO CLEAN
UP SB TO THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT
THE ADDITIONAL FEES IMPOSED BY
S. B. TO DO NOT APPLY TO THE
STATE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUME TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION OF
NEW REVENUE FROM THIS I SEVENTY
FIVE HIGH DOLLAR REAL ESTATE
DOCUMENTS RECORDING FEE. THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND STATE
TRANSACTIONS EXEMPTED BY THIS
BILL EQUATING TO ROUGHLY
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
TO THE COMMITTEE MISS RACE.
I'M SO GLAD TO HEAR THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE TAKEN CARE WE HAVE
MANY OF OUR FOSTER FAMILIES THAT
ARE. NOT BEING PAID AND IT
BECOMES SUCH A BURDEN SO I JUST
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING THIS IN THIS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER ABILITY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I MISSED
BECAUSE I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
THE SP TO CLEAN UP LANGUAGE.
A. I THINK THAT IT WE WOULD BE
UNANIMOUS IN SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE AMBIGUITY AND
THAT LANGUAGE AND THERE
CERTAINLY WAS AMBIGUITY IN LINE.
THAT LEGISLATURE PASSED THAT
WHAT LAST YEAR SO WE NEED TO
CLARIFY WHETHER OR NOT THAT FEE
APPLIES TO. STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOWEVER TO ME THAT
ISSUE IS SEPARATE FROM THE
QUESTION OF YOU KNOW SHOULD.
COUNTY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BE
REQUIRED TO PAY THIS FEE AND I
WONDER WHAT THE ARGUMENT. IS
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T ANOTHER SOME
HISTORICAL PRECEDENT.
BUT I HAVE A HARD TIME WHEN A
CONSTITUENT WHO IS A CONTRACTOR
COMES TO ME AND SAYS.
LOOK IF I HELPED BUILD A HOUSE
AND I'M GONNA RECORD A
MECHANIC'S LIEN BECAUSE I DIDN'T
GET PAID. I SHOULD HAVE TO PAY A
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLAR FEE BUT. A
COUNTY GOVERNMENT WHO DOESN'T
GET PAID.
A PROPERTY TAX BILL.
DOESN'T HAVE TO PAY THAT TO
pSMITH PROPERTIES I WONDER WHAT
THAT THE MEN THAT THE
CONSTITUENTS HATE IT WHEN WE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT EXEMPT
OURSELVES FROM FEES THAT WE ASK
THEM TO PAY THEY CALL THAT
HYPOCRISY AND. THEY CAN HAVE A
POINTS I WONDER WHAT YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT IS WHY SHOULD.
COUNTY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BE
EXEMPT FROM PAYING THAT FEE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I
THINK A YOU'VE RAISED A GOOD
POINT WHICH IS A POLICY POINT WE
DO THIS LANGUAGE THOSE
CLARIFYING TO THE ORIGINAL
INTENT.
S. B. TO A WE FELT IT WAS VERY
CLEAR THAT THESE ENTITIES WERE
EXEMPTED IN THAT LAW. ON WE
SUBSEQUENTLY HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE'S SOME DISAGREEMENT ON
THAT AND SO WE SEEK THIS IS JUST
CLARIFYING WHAT WAS OUR INTENT
IN THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION.
SO.
WHEN I HEARD YOU SAY IS WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT INTENDING TO OPEN
UP THE POLICY DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD HAVE
TO PAY THE INTENT WAS THEY
SHOULDN'T AND WE'RE JUST
CLARIFYING THAT.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU.
BUT BY THE WAY I STILL THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE THE DEBATE ABOUT
PAYING BECAUSE.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD AGREE
WITH THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
AS.
I DEFERRED TO THE CHAIR ON THAT
POINT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE ANOTHER FABULOUS
LEGISLATIVE ID.
ARMY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SO THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT WE HAVE TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO.
WE WILL PICK UP THE MOTION.
THOSE IN FAVOR OF SB.
ONE TWENTY.
ANTI SHORTS WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORTOF THE PROVISIONS IN SB
ONE TWENTY YOU TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO OUR RELATIVES AND
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS WHO STEP
UP IN EMERGENCIES TO PROVIDE
HOMES FOR KIDS IN FOSTER CARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRIORITIZING THE SPECS.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
OUR SUPPORTIVE OF THE I JUST AS
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE IS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL I'M IN SHARES THAT THE
WAGE SUPPLEMENT WILL BE
SUBSEQUENTLY APPLIED WHEN. STATE
MINIMUM WAGE PASS THE COUNTY
PROVIDE A WAGE ABSENT THE WAGE
SUPPLEMENT AMOUNT THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH C. SACKS
ORIGINAL UNDERSTANDING AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU INCLUDING THIS.
I'M IN A CURRENT YOUR TRAILER
BILL CLEAN UP AT ALL ALLOW VITAL
GUIDANCE AND CLARITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH COUNTIES ON
UNDERSTANDING THIS PROVISION.
NOW WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE. PROVISION TO PROVIDE OUR
FOSTER CARE PAYMENTS AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT I'LL APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE.
PRIVATIZING THIS ISSUE AND
APPRECIATE THE APPROACH TO
PROVIDE SOME STATE FUNDING.
.
TO ASSIST WITH THESE PAYMENTS
AND FOR COUNTIES TO RECEIVE
EXTENSION ON THAT FUNDING NOW
SHOULD THERE BE. FACTORS OUTSIDE
OF COUNTIES CONTROL IN THE
APPROVAL PROCESS THINKING.
SO CHAIR MEMBERS CHILDREN OF
ORSON PATH URBAN CARRIES A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
ARCHES SAYS PROVISIONS AND SP
ONE TWENTY THREE RIGHTS NEEDED
CLARIFICATIONS ACCOUNT IS TO
IMPLEMENT AYE TO SESAME THINK.
I THINK ADVANCE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH THE I TO
ASSESS AND RELATIVE PAYMENT
PROVISIONS OF SB ONE TWENTY. WE.
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
CLARITY THAT'S PROVIDED ON THE I
JUST S. WAGE SUPPLEMENTAL BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR COUNTIES AS A
NEGOTIATE. AND WE'RE ESPECIALLY
GRATEFUL FOR ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE AROUND PAYMENT AT THE TIME
OF PLACEMENTS FOR RELATIVES. I'M
WE'RE GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATIVE
OF ALL THE COLLABORATION
COMPROMISE ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON GOING
FORWARD SPRING ON THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION THANK YOU.
SUZANNE ANTIPHONAL CHILDREN NOW
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE AT
PROVISIONS TO PAY RELATIVES FAR
OUT FOSTER CARE.
AND QUIRK TUNES LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT THE FOSTER
KIDS IN LOS ANGELES PLACER AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTIES AND WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AND THANK
YOU FOR ADDRESSING THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU NAME OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWENTY.
OKAY SEEING NONE MOVING TO
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION IN.
LEVINE SP ONE TWENTY.
OKAY.
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND WE
HAVE A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALDWELL PLEASE
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ALLEN. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM AYE
COPIER CLEAR I TRAVIS ALLEN
CHAVIS HIGH CHIU.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER AYE HARPER AYE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE TACKY AYE LOW MOAN
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MELENDEZ MULLIN RESEARCHING
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE REYES.
YES I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STONE
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
WHAT I ICE TWENTY TWO?
THANK YOU ARE MOVING ON TO SPU
ONE TWENTY ONE THIS COSTA.
I THINK THIS IS OUR EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL WHICH HAS TWO MAIN
PROVISIONS THE FIRST OF WHICH
IS.
FOR STATE CHILDCARE SUBSIDY
PROGRAMS THE BILL AMENDS THE
EDUCATION CODE TO STREAMLINE AND
REDUCE DUPLICATION AND THE
REQUIREMENTS OF INDIVIDUALIZED.
COUNTY CHILD CARE PILOT PLANTS
AND CLARIFIES HOW LOCAL
CHILDCARE SUBSIDY POLICIES ME
SUPERSEDE STATE LAW AND
PARTICIPATING PILOT COUNTIES.
WE KNOW THAT THESE PARTICULAR
AMENDMENTS DO NOT RESULT IN COST
TO THE STATE IF ANYTHING BY
STREAMLINING THIS PROCESS WE
BELIEVE WE CAN RELY SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
THE SECOND PROVISION DEALS WITH
THE EVERY KID COUNTS A LANGUAGE
THAT WAS PART OF THE A CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET.
I IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET
WE APPROPRIATE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
ESTABLISH THAT EVERY KID COUNTS
COLLEGE SAVINGS MATCH GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS BILL SLIGHTLY
MODIFIED THE PROGRAM'S INITIAL
STRUCTURE AND TRANSFERS IT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE RESPONSIBILITIES
FROM THE SCHOLARSHIP INVESTMENT
BOARD TO THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THEY DISCUSSED.
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
IN THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SING NONE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF SB ONE
TWENTY ONE.
OKAY WE'VE A MOTION A SECOND ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE TWENTY ONE
FOR THE PUBLIC.
OKAY XENA WE'VE MOSHE SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TING AYE TING I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ALLEN. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I
THOUGHT THERE CLEAR I TRAVIS
CHáVEZ HIGH CHIU.
CHOI.
CHOI AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
FONG.
FONG BY GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
HARPER. AYE PERVERT AYE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
AYE LACKEY AYE ALONE. MATHIS BY
MATHIS AYE MEDINA.
BUT MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE. GREATNESS.
REYES AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
STONE.
STONE I VOEPEL. WEBER. WEBER AYE
WOOD.
WOULD I ICE TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY OF WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THOSE NUMBERS
ATTENDING.
NOPE QUE CAN I CHAIR AND.
.
S. B..
ONE ONE SIX.
SORRY DOT DETROIT. ALISON NAY
FOR SP ONE ONE SIX A FIRST TIME
WHO WE OUT ON.
FRISBEE ONE ONE SIX.
AND THE WOMAN SIX AND CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE.
LIKEWISE FOR WOULD.
WHAT I THINK YOU
LACKEY I ALSO?
FOR EVERYONE AND ANYONE SIXTEEN
I TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BURKE MISTER HARPER LIKE
OUT ON AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT OUT ON IS A YES TO A S.
B. ONE SIXTEEN AND OUT ON AS A
NO ON SP ONE EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
.
LACKEY WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD ON
ONE EIGHTEEN AS WELL I.
S. B. ONE EIGHTEEN LACKEY
.
SURE IS. A MISTER MULLIN LIKE
THAT ON AS WELL.
YOU KNOW.
YOU WANT SIXTEEN MULLIN.
WELL AND I.
S. B. ONE EIGHTEEN MULLIN.
WELL LIKE I.
S. B. ONE TWENTY MULLIN.
MULLIN I SP ONE TWENTY ONE
STOLEN.
MULLIN I
STEAM ALLEN.
ALLEN I.
S. B. ONE EIGHTEEN ALLEN.
ALLEN I SP ONE TWENTY ALLEN.
ALLEN I SP ONE TWENTY ONE ALLEN.
HELEN I
.
THANK YOU MISTER ALONG WITH THAT
WE WILL ADJOURN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU